[Music]
welcome
once again i am will torres one of the
admission officers
here at the stanford graduate school of
business
first session sharing your story one we
were talking about how do you
start your story in it i was talking a
lot about
think big what are some of the things
that you wish you can do if there was
no expectation no fear of failure what
would you do
from there kind of unpacking the things
that really excite you
to really get an understanding of what
that path forward might look like for
you
towards business school and beyond the
analogy was the journey you're gonna
hear that word a lot
what are the steps what did the path
look like to get from there to here
what does that look like ahead of you
what does that environment
around you look like how has that
impacted who you are and what that
journey looks like
so really thinking big what was your big
picture
from there we went to right into the
weeds of how do you distill that
into the written portions of the
application knowing that writing is
beyond just the essays
but technically you're writing the
resume and there are other blank spaces
throughout
that you can use in concert with each
other to help build a clear picture
of who you are how you're going to show
up in the classroom
and in our community and today we're
going to bring that to life
talking is going to be one of the most
energizing and exhausting things you're
probably going to do
in business school and a good chunk of
that is probably going to be covering
or sharing some part of your story
so how do we think about that during the
application
process and that is what we're going to
be focusing on today
so we're going to be talking about how
speaking and
sharing your story figures into the
application process
we'll talk a little bit about that tried
and true tool
the elevator pitch and then tell me
about a time when
kind of that infamous lead up to the
thing that i
actually really love as well apparently
i love a lot of things in admissions
uh but the behavioral-based interview uh
that's the interview style that stanford
uses and i want to give you a few tips
um and things that i've observed with my
colleagues
uh together we have maybe over a century
of admissions experience
and this is put together from some of
the learnings we've had observations and
things we would love to share with you
and then we're going to bring it full
circle this is session three
um and so hopefully over the course of
this we have given you the tools that
you might need
um so that you can try different things
see what fits
and as you go on apply those both in the
application process and
hopefully in other places in your life
as well so
a little bit of its disclaimer same
disclaimer that i've been giving all
week long
there's a lot of advice out there and i
feel like especially around the world
of networking and interviewing there's
so many schools of thought out there
definitely like listen see what's out
there find a process that works for you
i know everybody has a different style
everybody has a different strength
and so as you explore and test out
different things
find the spaces where you feel the most
comfortable
find the places and even afterwards how
do you recharge afterwards
right because for some people this can
feel like draining your battery
and you know there are also ways to
recharge it
um so let's play around see what we can
find out so there's going to be two main
parts
uh that we are going to be talking about
networking and the interview
so questions today we're going to be
focusing on parts
on these parts of the application
tomorrow we have another session with
dean moss where we're going to run the
whole gamut of things from
her tips what things have has she seen
over the course of her
her um career and and what are we
looking for in the application
but right now let's talk about
networking and the interview
so networking wise this can come in a
lot of
forms maybe you're talking to students
maybe you're talking alumni
maybe you're talking to an admissions
officer at an event
an event a fair you know so many
different spaces this might crop
up and in ways you might not expect
so one of the things that is going to
help carry you through this
is that elevator pitch you know when you
meet somebody
how do you leave that lasting impression
it might be quick
but you want it to be memorable these
tend to be between
20 to 30 seconds long again
um how long you might imagine that
elevator rides would be
you know if you're in that crowded space
how do you talk to that person so you
pique their interest
how do you let them know what is special
about the thing you're talking about
maybe it's yourself how do you build
that connection
so that they say hey let's you know
let's connect after this
let me i want to learn more that's where
hopefully we're going to try to get us
today
we're going to look at this elevator
pitch in a couple of different
forms and formats try them on and see
what feels best for you
so here is a basic structure that i see
i've heard this
many many many times and i think it's a
great foundation
i'm blank i'm originally from blank
i went to school where i studied a topic
i work at a company where i am currently
you know this is my title
i want to here's my goal and this is why
i'm interested in your school
so if you have a paper and pencil handy
maybe open up a browser so you can type
along
or just think through it sit down
and write this out write it out
including your bits of information
so for me i'm will i'm ridgid from
california
so on and so forth i'll give you a
little bit of time to do that
this is going to be the foundation of
our first
exercise so let me uh turn on my timer i
want to make sure i'm giving you
that full minute to jot all of this down
so this is also going to be an exercise
in speed writing as you fill this out
think through the times where you've
interacted with folks before
remember the times where it felt
successful think about the times where
you said
that could have gone better right even
as we
practice some of those things i
encourage you to step back and think
about the process
as we were doing some of the exercises
in the other sessions
i had that um mental model did it go the
way you thought it would
how did it feel so even as you're doing
the things here
even as you're interacting and trying
them out in in real time
it's always worth stepping back to see
okay you know
let's analyze let's learn and let's grow
so that's getting us to the minute
this is what i call this is your basic
pitch
great as a foundation so
you know we have it here's our base okay
so say yours out loud maybe just whisper
it if you're in a place that might be
strange or just
read through it in your head and listen
to that mental voice
this can often be a great structure
but sometimes structures can also be
limiting
so use this but try your best
not to get too stuck if possible and
here's
why sometimes there are going to be
um i might be talking to a lot of people
and the way to be memorable is sometimes
find that connection
you might start with that one thread
that the other person
can also associate with and from there
that can open up the conversation
and help drive towards you know some
kind of
mini relationship that kind of that
could spark in the future into something
fruitful
so now let's do the elevator pitch
the remix notice over the course of the
week i've been
trying to instill some activity today
for sure there's going to be a little
bit of levity some humor
because hopefully networking
well you know hopefully it's at least
not a drag
it might be fun but hopefully at least
the interview later on will be fun for
you
and that's what we strive for so i want
the prep for you to be enjoyable as well
so let's get to that remix we're talking
about connection
sometimes you can flip around the pieces
of your basic pitch
so that you know start with that spark
and that actually opens up the door so
here's another form of it
so go ahead write your pitch again
this time start with you know maybe the
institution that you went with
and notice how there's that two that's
already including the other person it's
building some kind of rapport
even though they haven't yet engaged
with you
when you say you majored in or kind of
whatever structure you have as part of
your basic pitch
that can also be somewhere where you add
a little bit of flavor
notice i put the dot dot that ellipses
there because maybe that could be some
observation of something from your
school
um maybe it could be some observation
from something in your
um from your career or whatever it is
that shared connection might be
this is often helpful if you know that
person or you know the kind of the
environment that you might be heading
into
or as you practice hearing it or it
comes up in conversation
being able to adapt on the fly
so hopefully that gave you enough time
to rewrite your pitch
finding that point of connection you're
going to write your pitch
one more time sometimes
the best thing that you can connect with
someone over is a shared interest
or even a interest maybe you don't know
it's shared just yet
but when i'm at fairs and people talk
about their interests that's where i'm
like
oh maybe you might be interested in this
or
oh i've heard about that tell me more
that is often an opening
for conversation and this is one of the
ways that i like to approach
um networking i i'm honestly really bad
at it
i might be okay talking to a screen i'm
fine when it comes to
speaking and connecting with people so
that i can help out and be of service
but when i'm trying to do something for
myself or build towards something it
feels really awkward
and i know that might be similar for
some of you out there
but if you flip networking and the
elevator pitch on its head and think
about it as
hey let's figure out a shared interest
spark that mini relationship and see
where it goes from there
it might make things easier and you
might actually meet some really cool
people
who beyond whatever the intent of that
networking event might have been
end up being some really good friends so
how are we going to approach this
that interest pathway so i'm blank
i'm interested in this and then feel
free to stop after that one it's going
to be the same
kind of lines after that but go ahead
and take a moment
and figure out oh hey what is something
you are interested in
especially as it pertains to business
education i know in the past people have
been
um talking about hey i'm interested in
clean energy
maybe it's some of the things that you
spoke about in the q a box earlier when
you were introducing yourselves
maybe it's talking about passion for uh
you know making education accessible in
central america
so even as you're thinking about your
motivations
that could be something you share up
front so that you can build that
relationship and already kind of cut to
the chase
without having to kind of dance around
the bush
so here's an example um
we're gonna add a call to action to also
give it that extra um
so that you know it's an invitation for
engagement
so now we get to the example so
here's mine i'm will i'm originally from
california
i went to ucla where i studied marine
biology i work at stanford where i'm an
admissions officer
i want to grow as an admissions
professional and this is why i'm
interested in your school
take a moment feel that out
it was fine you might know something
about me now
and are you necessarily interested
maybe maybe not let's try the remix
i'm will i went to ucla too uh i majored
in marine biology like way off in south
campus
oh what about you okay that could be a
spot for conversation
i'm originally from california and then
you can go from there
you're opening it up for conversation as
you think about hey
i i want to ucla too notice how
your body might also react to that when
you're in that script mode sometimes
it becomes so memorized that it just
comes out
and it's hard to emote right it's hard
to connect when you're just
hitting some high level bullet points
but as you start
talking about experience emotion and
body language start to pick up
and isn't that part of how relationships
and talking
are you hopefully you're finding some
engagement that way
and then when you talk about interest
maybe you really do light up
let's talk about the interest approach
hi i'm will
i'm really interested in making business
school accessible by democratizing
access to
application information i really want to
continue growing as an admission
professional
and that's that's why i'm interested in
your school so
take a moment how did that land
compare that to hi i'm will uh i'm
originally from california
i went to ucla and i studied marine
biology
two kind of different approaches
towards some same goal one you know i
don't quite know where you're going
through to yet
the other hey especially if it's on
topic if it's
something related to where we are or
you'll
something that you're interested in
connecting over hey
you know maybe this person has that
spark
and let's continue from there so
take a look at the three of yours right
now take a moment
read through them if you have the
ability to read them out loud once
and feel it see how you feel
as you're reading them okay
if you're not in a place where you're
able to vocalize
read it and listen to that internal
voice in your head
which one of these three is the one that
you feel
most connected to which one feels the
most natural to you
one is not necessarily more or less
effective than the other you know each
might have its turn
and i want you to be able to navigate
between the three of them
so that depending on what situation
you're in you're able to adapt and pick
which tool within your tool kit you're
gonna use
so i'm gonna give you a little bit of
time so you can actually hear the voice
inside of your head
and not mine
all right hopefully you're able to at
least give some of those a little bit of
a try
from one end of the spectrum there's a
little bit more of that monologue
from the other end there's that dialogue
if you add a call to action at the end
that's often an opening for conversation
and conversation can really continue and
that's
again another one of those threads that
maybe makes kind of creating that
mosaic and landscape of the things that
you're interested in that much clearer
so let's start to bridge that over into
the interview
so networking thinking about the
elevator pitch
kind of expansive can be used in many
applications
so let's talk a little bit more about
the interview and i'll start with
there's a couple questions here so let's
knock out some of the logistic questions
um as we get started so stanford we do
use behavioral based interviews
typically there's about two to three
interviews for every spot in the class
so that means not everybody's going to
be interviewed
um but if you are interviewed hey that's
a great sign
these are conducted mostly by our alumni
um sometimes our admission officers
there have been times where i've been
able to do interviews
and i always really enjoy them being
able to hear about your experiences
from your own voice and perspective
is so enlightening and i find a very
valuable part of the whole
application process applications are
also
kind of holistic not kind of they are
holistic when we're doing these reviews
and sometimes it might feel because this
is a step after you've submitted
that this might be a make it or break it
instance and it's not that way
after your interview we will receive the
report and then
take that look at the whole document
again take a look at all of the
different pieces of your application to
see
hey where does intellectual vitality
demonstrate a leadership potential
and personal qualities and contributions
shine for this individual
and then we make the decision on the
whole so
that's a little bit about the logistics
of it so
by nature also these invitations for
interviews come a little bit after we
start reading you know
we have to be able to start making some
of those assessments and they do come
through on a rolling basis
we try our best to be as communicative
as possible
uh through the application process so
you know what to expect
i understand that as you're waiting you
know because there is no set
day when you may get that interview
invite that anxiety and stress might
build
and if you put your best foot forward
you know
hopefully you're proud of where you are
and just get excited about the potential
um rather than waiting on the anxiety so
might be very easy for me to say on this
side of the table but
um give it a try so
let's talk more about the interview um
tell me about a time when
and this is really the core question
kind of the fundamental basis of the
behavioral based interview
past performance is a great indicator
for how you might behave again
in the future so at the beginning
bringing it back to the story and why
it's part
of this um sharing your story series
you've had an opportunity to think big
what are the things that you're looking
towards um what is on your horizon
for traditional interviews you are going
to be asked about your opinions your
thoughts maybe there might be a
hypothetical situation or something
along those lines
at stanford we're going to be focusing
on behavioral basic questions
so we're really going to be asking you
about your past the footsteps that
you've gotten to get here
what did that path look like what was
the environment
and the circumstances that shaped the
way that you
got to where you are today so really
specific anecdotes
examples and experiences the great thing
about this
is that you are already the expert in
you
and so from here it's not about having
to think forward and
hey does this plan make sense but really
think backwards
reflect and remember so
here are a few tips and best practices
as we enter the process
so remember reflect process connect
use this phrase at least once in each
one of the sessions
remember instances from your past
reflect on the circumstances around it
what led to it you know what happened
who was involved process you know
how did that connect to the greater
whole what were the things that you did
the hows and the y's now that
hindsight is 20 20 let's process the way
those things work together to
so you actually got from point a to
point b or maybe you got
from point a to lower case a stalled a
little bit
went back to the drawing board and then
got to a different version of b
and then connect connect the dots
between the different things if there
was learning that happened
you know where else might you have
applied that learning
you know have there been themes how did
that theme emerge or
you know if there was a a really
important strategic insight you had
did you have another one where was it
what were the things that kind of
sparked that
that experience for you so remember
reflect process connect
so a non-exhaustive list of things that
you might want to think about
you know how do you narrow down that
list of
possible life experiences that you want
to like brush up on
so a few things to think about what are
things that you're proud of
this can be both in your professional
life your personal life
uh the things that you do
extracurricularly
remember when we talked about
intellectual vitality demonstrated
leadership potential
and personal qualities and contributions
as being background agnostic
and context dependent they can emerge
you know these competencies
can emerge anywhere in your life so
really lean into that
try to think first you know what are
some things within the last few years
just because those are some of the
freshest and probably the easiest
examples to remember
that said maybe you did something really
needy and some something that you're
really proud of
but maybe it was a little bit more
distant in your past
that's okay as well and you know you
might also be asked
what about something a little bit more
recently so definitely share if that
experience was very meaningful for you
and you know just be ready with a few
others in your back pocket
to explore with whoever your interviewer
is
the other question i often get is should
i have a lot of different
experiences and should i answer each
question
with a different experience or is it
okay to stay with one
and it is okay to stay with one some
examples can be really meaty
there might be different ways that you
discuss it based on the question that's
being asked
so lean into whichever feels comfortable
listen to the question the question will
help guide you
um that's what the interviewer is there
for hopefully this is a conversation
and the questions are just that spark
for where that dialogue can occur
so that we can learn more about you and
try to pull out those pieces of
excellence
those competencies so that you know they
can share it back with us as a
admissions committee okay so
what are other things to consider as you
are
going through this remember reflect
process connect
um like cycle hate me there
not just you know you know this was
my project at work you know here's the
situation but really take me there
who is involved who are the stakeholders
how did you feel when things happen
remember
some of these details and even though
they might feel a little
like really nuanced and fine-grained
just
sit yourself back into that example and
if you are able to remember it with that
vibrancy you know
close your eyes that big picture if you
close your eyes and see yourself there
again
i think you're headed in the right
direction let me
like see it through your eyes and hear
it through your words so
don't just remember but practice
verbalizing you know what that situation
was
okay star so this is one of those
structures that is really powerful it's
a common framework for how to
respond to almost any interview question
really
so situation task action result
i'm not really gonna go much into detail
here because there's a lot of really
great content
that you can um discover on your own and
i do encourage you to look at different
frameworks out there and kind of
put on the ones that feel right for you
what i will talk about
is something that you know i kind of
refer to as star plus
what does that mean so even as you're
thinking about the situation
task action result you know there are
extra elements that might be handy
and helpful for us in the process right
so context
was it the first time you did something
was it the first time your team did
something
was it the first time your company did
it
was it the first time this was done in
your industry
that context like that can be very
helpful
um remember how as part of that
background agnostic
context dependent piece was context is a
really
helpful piece of the evaluative process
for us to understand you know
what was the landscape you were
navigating as you were expressing some
of these competencies
so help us understand you know what was
the context for for this example
we talked a lot about impact was there
scope scale
why was it important what was the
significance of this instance or this
outcome
on you know whoever was impacted by it
and then so what take a step back and
think
okay how does this connect right why is
this important to me
there's a purpose that there's a reason
why i'm talking about this so let's feel
good about that
and then connect that back because
that's the way you're gonna really be
able to anchor in
and the things that are the most
meaningful for you and those are the
examples
that hopefully you will also you're most
likely going to be able to articulate
remember and kind of delve deeply
the best right the things that are
meaningful for you the things that have
really made an
impression on who you are you might be
asked kind of to switch midstream give
us a different detail
and so that's also part of that comfort
level of knowing your whole story
that if we ask you to look to the left
you're able to and then you're still
able to talk about the rest of that
image
because you live that experience you are
the expert in it
so these next two we're gonna do a
little bit of a pilot
we've never done this before and i can
definitely say i've never done this
before
but since we aren't able to interact and
i'm not able to give feedback to you
directly
i am going to do a little bit of a demo
so i
i know someone said earlier that they
are into improv comedy
please don't judge me too harshly on
this because this is also my first time
with improv
i'm gonna give you a little bit of time
in the q and a box
can you please put a profession and
uh tell me about a timeline situation
give me
give me an interview question tell me a
time when uh of something you're proud
of
tell me about a time when you were
challenged so i'm gonna give you all
30 seconds profession and
an example you would like me to unpack
for you so here we go
30 seconds
i see at least one in there let's get
those coming through
nice okay oh ooh i'm loving some of
these
got about 10 more seconds to put
something in
all right in three two one and please
stop
typing okay this next piece
um we're gonna make use of that upvote
button so things might be flying a
little quickly here
what i'm gonna do is i actually have two
things that i'm going to demo for you
and of the top five things that get
upvoted
i'm gonna choose one to for each demo so
of the top five i'll be doing two of
them
so i'll give you about a minute because
it takes a little bit of time to scroll
through
find one that you enjoy but i'll give
everyone a minute to look at the
different
sessions and um questions to upvote
notice i'm already getting kind of
nervous here so um
have at it and i am going to go off
screen for a second
um so i can take a deep breath and a
drink of water
all right keep those up votes coming
we'll leave voting open for another 10
seconds or so
all right and go ahead and stop let me
take
a look through and see what the top five
are
so from leah uh clown tell me about a
time you have failed
uber driver tell me your most
challenging customer experience these
are good
um zookeeper tell me about a time when
you had to deal with a difficult
conversation with a co-worker
and um finance tell me about a time you
had an ethical challenge
all right so for each of these demos
i'm going to do it twice so each is
going to demonstrate
one thing for you to consider um maybe
as a way to help kind of guide you
through this process
as you are answering questions so these
could be things that you try on
as you're in the interview or in
practice so
the first i'll do clown
uh tell me about a time you failed okay
so
here we go so there was this one time we
were at a
party and people came out and we were
really excited but then i started
sweating
and i forgot what i was supposed to say
and i kind of started stumbling
um and i couldn't remember anything um
like nobody laughed and i think that was
one of the most
um hurtful kind of embarrassing moments
of my life
um and from there i really took it on to
say hey maybe i should
take a little bit of the pressure off of
myself and approach it and have fun
myself
um you know i'm a clown and it should be
all about having fun
okay hopefully that worked okay
this we're gonna try this again
so i'm a clown and in my career you know
it's all about how do you make people
laugh um and this one time
crickets uh we went out i was so nervous
because i really wanted to make sure
people
were having a good time at this event
nothing
um no laughter not even a chuckle um
maybe the only laugh was an embarrassed
laugh and someone embarrassed for me um
i knew then and there that maybe maybe i
had to rethink how i approach things
i should be having fun as well and so
that was one of my biggest learnings
here from that failure
to have fun because if i'm not having
fun
you're not having fun okay
two different frame ways of answering
the same question
um maybe not as interesting as you might
have been expecting
given that we're in an interview um and
you know you might be talking about any
profession or experience
but in the first i just kind of started
talking i actually started rambling and
found myself going in a different
direction before i caught myself and
brought
me back to the question at hand the
second
i mapped it out for you i told you what
my job was
what i was going to talk about what that
failure was
i told you about the failure and then i
told you the learning from the failure
if you map it out it has this nice
effect of both keeping you
in bounds so having a nice starting
point as well as an
ending point and that can be really
helpful for folks who
tend to weave very elaborate stories
or tend to continue beyond your point
and it helps your interviewer already
understand where this is going
like on a map you have a starting point
and an end point
give them the lay of that land map it
out for them so that they know which
parts to be looking for in that first
question
you might have been waiting for okay
what's the point here whereas in the
second one
that point was a lot easier to pick up
and also a lot easier to communicate
from my end so
give that a try okay so
this next one uh let's see where did it
go
we're gonna do the zookeeper one uh time
i had
a difficult conversation with a
co-worker
um and clearly i'm a little biased so i
was
gonna choose that one i'm so happy i
jumped into the top five so i could
okay here we go so
this one time um we were at the zoo
um where we were working and we had this
really
um strange incident that kept happening
we kept
finding um the antelope with the lions
and every day every night that was
something that kept happening
uh we didn't know where it was coming
from we launched an investigation
um cameras were broken so that didn't
help uh
finally we figured out that it was one
of our co-workers um
they thought it was really cute to have
like a whole safari in one space
and we had to talk to them and tell them
that wasn't possible and they we had to
let them go
so i'm gonna stop the story there
okay next let me try that again
um so i'm a zookeeper and this we had a
difficult conversation that i had to
really take the lead on um while there
was
a period of time where we kept fighting
the antelope with the lions
which didn't always turn out well for
the antelope so
i launched an investigation i tried to
think of what are the
different ways that this could happen i
tried to look into the camera
situation but those were broken um and
we realized after talking to a number of
folks
um i was able to trace it back to one of
my co-workers
um i talked to management and they were
they said
this is one of your direct supervisees
you're gonna need to tell them we have
to let them go so
i had the really difficult situation of
telling someone
who really loved their job and really
wanted to create a fun
lively exhibit that they were fired
okay hopefully those two situations
illustrated something that came out
maybe clearly as an interviewer i do
start to pick
it up there is a difference between we
and i right there is no i in team
but there is an i in admit and i i'm
just kind of joking with this
kind of phrase but there is some truth
to it as
well i'm guilty of this i talk in the
wii
all the time the last time i interviewed
um within the office
dean moss was one of my was my
interviewer and she
said will you keep saying we
what did you do and so i encourage you
as you're thinking about these examples
what did you do
even if it was a group exercise if it
was a group that got from point a to
point b
you had some role in there what was your
contribution
was it the idea was it the late night
that really got you to that breakthrough
was it engaging and getting senior
administration on board with you
so it's okay to talk about i
right i know i mentioned in other
sessions that sometimes there is a
cultural element
maybe it's a community or family or
personal
kind of um situation where you don't
really talk about yourself
this is one of those times that i
encourage you to
embrace that discomfort and if you catch
yourself going there it's always okay to
name it
name it to yourself because once you
name something
you're able to say hey okay now we can
work towards addressing that
so take me there walk me and talk me
through all the details
star situation task action results
star plus give me some of that context
as you're planning and remembering
things
what were the circumstances that
surrounded it
what were some of those ripple effects
map it out
let me know as your interviewer where
you're gonna go with this
let me know so that i can be paying
attention and really
focus on like the details and the
competencies that come out
rather than trying to figure out where
we're going with the story center
yourself
and that is a phrase that i've been
saying pretty consistently through the
week
even though we do celebrate
collaborative effort and
the gsb is definitely one of those
places where collaboration is
part of the experience right how do you
support others
and challenge each other to grow to the
fullest extent
i mean the policy of grade
non-disclosure really exemplifies that
you know not publishing lists of gpa or
class rank to recruiters
this frees you to help each other to ask
for help
and to create that support network so
you're always lifting each other up
and you're part of it and you should be
the center of this discussion
so don't worry about not feeling like
you're being a teammate by using the
phrase i
i really do want to know about what you
did and how you did it
so networking interview two
parts of the application process that
are going to be
um really dependent and really fueled by
your voice
um so definitely practice find someone
you trust
maybe this is an instance where you
practice on that networking side
invite someone at work to a one-on-one
so you can learn more about
their kind of job responsibilities and
role
sometimes you know loki interviewing
like that
will help you as someone who's speaking
on the other end you know
feel comfortable about you know this is
just a conversation
talking to people really does help with
this and i know that might be exhausting
for some
it might be energizing for others so
find those times
where you know you're willing to exert
that and find those times where you
and honor the times you just need to
recharge
and this brings us here
so when i started uh you know
in admissions like i there was a lot of
learning
i realized that as i was growing up i
knew actually nothing about what it
meant to apply to college
or even grad school it often felt like
looking back there might have been some
kind of hidden curriculum to
how to get in and how to thrive
and so my goal with the events this week
and my goal
with um the sharing your story series
was to illuminate the process
so that you know you can put your best
fit forward so that you can understand
both
our process you know just to be
comfortable and know that there is a
system that cares
takes this very seriously and is rooting
for you
and know what's on your side of the net
understand the things that are under
your control and the things that you are
able
to shape and shine and really mold
into you know something that you are
proud of when you click that submit
button
the goal of application week was to help
you
figure out the ways pick up some
frameworks some tools
and things that you can experiment with
so that you know you can again
put your best foot forward and see where
this journey will take you
this slide is um you know a little
anti-climatic and that's on purpose
this is just one step of your journey
and maybe the least exciting step
probably the least exciting step
you have business school ahead of you if
you're not going to business school
maybe whatever career path you're going
on you know
some of these things might be helpful
you know that what matters exercise
those five whys can help you figure out
you know
should i move should i take this job
what will that opportunity look like for
me what is my north star
and so hopefully um this is again just
the beginning
of that crazy canvas and that big
picture that you're gonna be able to
explore
and that horizon that you're gonna be
able to reach towards
so i'm gonna leave you all with this
it's an inscription uh
on the cornerstone of gsb campus and i'm
gonna just read it word for word
because uh it is that meaningful um and
that meaningful for me
dedicated to the things that haven't
happened yet and the people who are
about to dream
them up y'all dream
big all right
with that i'm gonna take a moment go
ahead
and go into the q a box you know answer
whatever questions you might have
and i also really encourage you all to
tune in tomorrow
uh to the dean's office hours with
kirsten moss
uh it's a fireside chat where i'm gonna
be uh just
you know shooting the breeze with the
dean of nba admissions and
uh financial aid um to really get her
perspective
on this whole application journey it's a
journey that i hope that you have
enjoyed so far
um and even if you decide you know maybe
this is the end of my journey
that it was enjoyable and fruitful so
here's a question
is networking with current stanford
students and alums important to the
admissions process
and how is that shown in the application
and so
my favorite part of this answer is no
you do not have to have interacted with
any student
or alum or even attended a stanford
event
we do not practice what's called
demonstrated interest
by you submitting your application
that's all you need to let us know that
you're interested in applying and
attending
so please don't feel any pressure that
you have to reach out talk to someone
especially if there's no one in your
network or you don't have the time or
resources to do so
that is not a part of the process at all
we are here hosting events so hopefully
we can help you
um kind of understand and feel
comfortable and confident as you go
through the journey
and that's all these events are for so
no
you do not have to interact with us at
all
okay question about managing
vulnerability
when we talk about the paths taken and
what our circumstances and histories
look like
how do we look at difficulties setbacks
objectively negative experiences such as
work injuries
some stories have uglier elements than
others but the learnings may
be significant and cheer worthy you
caught it at the end and you've said it
i think way more beautifully than i
could have
the learnings may be significant and
share worthy
if those learnings are then they are
significant right those are the things
that you want to anchor on
let us know enough about the situation
that we understand what was going on so
if it was a work injury
maybe that that's where you can leave it
you don't need to go into the grizzly
detail
um so keep it at the level um
you know also read the room i think
that's going gonna be one of those
um things that you're also gonna be
getting a lot of practice with
for some folks like with me you might
get the sense that it's you can go there
and you know
go ahead and with others you know you
might feel like
hey we don't have that relationship just
yet in this time and space
let's keep it a little bit more high
level in detail but really go in on the
learnings
so it's also going to be a little bit of
dialogue between you and the person
and you and yourself see how you're
feeling in that moment
um let's see question about the demo
hopefully it was more clear than it
sounded coming up then it sounded coming
out of my mouth
um four questions around failure or
mistake is it better to include evidence
of how you've improved in addition to
what you've learned
i would say sometimes yeah sometimes no
way
it's case dependent right if
that is the point of it so maybe the
question is
hey can you tell me about a time where
you've
had a failure um and what did you learn
from it usually there's gonna be some
cue there that'll let you know okay
should we be talking about the learning
or should we
be talking about the growth you know
sometimes that learning and growth go
hand in hand
um if there's time if there's space
if you feel like you haven't gone on for
too long
go ahead and share those extra elements
with us what i will say is and this is
where i said it might be case dependent
sometimes folks might go for an extended
period of time
i have definitely had interviews where i
asked one question
and these these are 45 minute interviews
45 to
an hour um and i only got through two
questions
so also be conscious of the time it
should be a conversation
and so you know if you have that time
take that pause
see where the conversation is going if
you have that room go go there
if not allow your interviewer to help
guide you on what they're trying to pick
up on because we
we will thank you
everyone for joining us i am so thrilled
to have been able to premiere
application week and the share your
story series with you
i hope you have found this helpful
please go ahead and share any
feedback you have with us in the poll if
you have any questions
commentary things that you would like to
see us do in the future
let us know email us that's the way i
learn
what the things we should be doing are
so any guidance from you
incites inspiration here's to innovation
and here's to
dreaming big and doing better so with
that
thank you all i hope to see you around
soon
stay safe and remember dream big y'all